[Music]
welcome to the future of life institute
podcast
i'm lucas perry today we have a special
episode for you
with steven batchelor stephen is a
secular and skeptical buddhist teacher
and practitioner with many years under
his belt
in a variety of different buddhist
traditions
you've probably heard often on this
podcast about the dynamics of the
race between the power of our technology
and the wisdom with which we manage it
this podcast is primarily centered
around
the wisdom portion of this dynamic and
how
we might cultivate wisdom and how that
relates
to the growing power of our technology
steven and i get into discussing the
cultivation of wisdom what awakening
might entail or look like and also his
views
on embracing existential risk and
existential threats
as for a little bit more background we
can think of
ourselves as contextualized in a world
of existential threats that are
primarily created
due to the kinds of minds that people
have and how we behave
particularly how we decide to use
industry and technology and science and
the kinds of
incentives and dynamics that are born of
that
and so cultivating wisdom here in this
conversation
is seeking to try to understand how we
might
better gain insight into and grow beyond
the worst parts of human nature
things like hate greed and delusion
which motivate and help to cultivate
the manifestation of existential risks
the flip side of understanding
the ways in which hate greed and
delusion
motivate and lead to the manifestation
of existential risk
is also uncovering and being interested
in the project
of human awakening and developing into
our full potential
so this just means that whatever
idealized
kind of version you think that you might
want to be or that you might strive
to be there is a path to getting there
and this podcast is primarily interested
in that path and how that path relates
to
living in a world of existential threat
and how we might relate
to existential risk and its mitigation
this podcast contains a bit of buddhist
jargon in it i do my best in this
podcast to define the words to the best
of my ability i am not an expert but
i think that these definitions will help
to bring a bit of context and
understanding
to some of the conversation stephen
batchelor is a contemporary buddhist
teacher and
writer best known for his secular or
agnostic approach to buddhism
stephen considers buddhism to be a
constantly evolving culture of awakening
rather than a religious system based on
immutable dogmas and beliefs through his
writings translations and teaching
stephen engages in a critical
exploration of buddhism's role in the
modern world
which has earned him both condemnation
as a heretic
and praise as a reformer and with that
let's get into our conversation with
steven batchelor
thanks again so much for coming on i've
been really excited and looking forward
to this conversation
and i just wanted to start it off here
with a quote by albert einstein that i
thought would set the mood in the
context
a human being is a part of the whole
called by us
universe a part limited in time and
space
he experiences himself his thoughts and
feelings as something separated from the
rest
a kind of optical delusion of his
consciousness
this delusion is a kind of prison for us
restricting us to our personal desires
into affection for a few persons nearest
us our task must be to free ourselves
from this prison by widening our circle
of compassion to embrace all living
creatures
and the whole of nature in its beauty
nobody is able to
achieve this completely but the striving
for such achievement is in itself
a part of the liberation and a
foundation of inner security
this quote to me is compelling because
one it comes from someone who
is celebrated as one of the greatest
scientists that have
ever lived and so in that sense it's a
calling for
the spiritual journey it seems from
someone
who for people who are skeptical of
something like
the project of awakening or whatever a
secular dharma might be
or look like i think it sets up well the
project
i mean he talks about here how this idea
of separation is a kind of optical
delusion of his consciousness
he sets it up as the problem of trying
to arrive at experiential truth
and this project of self-improvement so
it's in the spirit of this
i think seeking to become and live
an engaged and fulfilled life that i
am interested and motivated in having
this conversation with you
and so with that in mind the problem it
seems that we have currently in the
21st century is what max tegmark and
others have called the race between the
power of our technology
and the wisdom with which we manage it
so i'm basically interested in
discussing and exploring how to grow
wisdom
and about how to grow into and develop
human potential so that we can manage
powerful things like technology
well i love the quote i think i've heard
it before
and i've come across a number of similar
statements that einstein has made over
the years of his life and i've always
been impressed by that
as you say this is a man who's not
regarded remotely as a religious or a
spiritual figure and yet obviously a
highly sensitive man
a man who has plumbed the depths of
physics in a way that has transformed
our world
so clearly someone with enormous insight
and understanding of the kind of
universe we live in
and yet at the same time in these sort
of passages we realize that he's not
just
the stereotyped detached scientists
separated out from the world looking at
things clinically
and trying to completely subtract his
own subjectivity
and this i think is often the problem
with the scientific approaches
the idea is that you have to get
yourself out of the way in order to
somehow see things as they really are
einstein breaks that stereotype very
well
and recognizes the need that if we are
to evolve
as human beings and not just as
scientists who get increasingly
clear and maybe very deep understandings
into the workings of the universe
something else is needed but of course
einstein himself does not seem to really
have any kind of
methodology as to how that might be
achieved he seems to be
calling upon something he may consider
to be
an innate human capacity or quality
his words resonate very much
in terms of certain philosophies certain
spiritual and religious traditions
but we don't really see any kind of
program or practice that would actually
lead to what he recognizes to be so
crucial
and i found the final comment he makes
a bit deflating he says he seems to
think it has to do with inner security
which is a highly subjective and i would
think
rather limited goal to achieve given
what he's just
laid out as his vision yeah that's
wonderfully said
and you can help unpack and show the
depths of your skepticism
particularly about buddhism but also
your interest in creating what you call
a secular dharma
you know we're on a planet with ancient
wisdom traditions which
have a lot to say about human
subjectivity so einstein is setting up
this project of
seeing through what he says and takes to
be a kind of delusion of consciousness
the sense of
experiencing oneself and thoughts and
feelings is something separate
and this restricting us to caring most
about our personal desires into
affection
i mean here he seems to be very
explicitly
tapping into concepts in buddhism which
have been explored
like non-self and emptiness and
non-duality
hey this is post podcast lucas here and
i just wanted to
try and explain a few terms that were
introduced here
like non-self emptiness and non-duality
and i'll do my best to explain them but
i'm not an expert
and other people who think about this
kind of stuff might have
a different take or give a different
explanation but i will do my best
so i think it's best to first think
about the universe 13.7 billion
years ago as an unfolding continuous
process
which contextualized within the
unfolding of the universe is the process
of evolution which has led to
human beings so there's this deep
grounded
connection of the human mind and human
nature
and just being human with the very
ground of being and the unfolding
of everything yet in that non-folding
there is
this construction of a dualistic world
model
which is very fitness enhancing where
you
are constructing this model of self
and a model of the world this
self other dualistic conceptual
framework
born of this evolutionary process is
fitness enhancing it's helpful and it's
useful
yet it is a fabrication a
epistemic construction which is imposed
upon a process
for survival reasons and so nonduality
comes in and simply rejects this
dualistic
construction and says things are not
separate
things are not to one undivided without
a second
this means that once one sees all of
this
dualistic construction and fabrication
as it is then one
enters what i might say is something
more like i don't know mind
where one isn't relying on this
conceptual dualistic fabrication to
ultimately know
or one doesn't take it as what reality
ultimately is as divided into all these
things like self and other
and tables and chairs and stars and
galaxies
non-self and emptiness are
both very much related to this non-self
is the view that the self is also this
kind of construction or fabrication
which under experiential and conceptual
analysis
just falls apart and reveals that
there is no core or essence to you
there's nothing to find there is no self
but
merely the continual unfolding of
empty ephemeral condition phenomena
where emptiness here means that the self
and all objects that you think exist
are empty of intrinsic existence and are
merely these kind of ephemeral
appearances based on causes and
conditions which
when those causes and conditions no
longer sustain for that thing
to appear in that current form the thing
dissolves
in non-duality there's a sense of no
coming no going
there's no real start or beginning or
end to anything
there is this continual unfolding
process
where something like birth and death are
abstractions or constructions which are
imposed on
a non-dual continuous process
and so the claims of non-self emptiness
and nonduality
are all both ontological claims about
how the universe actually is but they're
also experiential claims
about how we can shift our consciousness
into
a more awake state where we have insight
into
the nature of our experience into the
nature of things and
we're able to shift into a clear
non-conceptual seeing
of something like non-dual awareness or
emptiness or non-self
this might entail something like
noticing the sense of self it becoming
an
object of witnessing there's no longer
an identification with self and so
there's space from it
there might eventually be a dropping
away of sense of self
where all that's left is consciousness
and its contents
without a center where there isn't a
distance
between witnesser and what is perceived
all there is is consciousness and
everything is
perceived infinitely close where
everything is basically just made of
consciousness and
where consciousness is no longer
structured by this dualistic
framework and so a layer of fabrication
drops away
and there's just consciousness and this
deep sense of interconnectivity
and being this is what i think einstein
is pointing towards when he says
our experience of ourselves as separated
from the rest of the universe
is a kind of optical delusion of our
consciousness
i think he is pointing towards
how the constructed sense of self and
the dualistic fabrication of a
self other world model populated by
objects and things and other people
and then buying into these constructions
as kind of an ultimate representation
of how things are where there are all
these things with an intrinsic
independent existence with a kind of
essence
rather than being this non-dual
undifferentiated
unfolding continuous process which can
be said to be neither same nor different
which
there can neither be said to not be a
self or
be a self and so i think this is what he
is pointing in the direction
of and why i point out that there are
other wisdom traditions which have been
thinking about and practicing
cultivating these kinds of insights and
awareness for many years
so back to the conversation and as you
said he doesn't have a practice or a
system
for arriving at an experiential
understanding of these things
yet there are traditions which have long
studied and practiced
this project yes this is absolutely
correct
and myself and many of my peers and
colleagues and friends have spent their
lives
exploring these wisdom traditions
in my own case this has been various
forms of buddhism primarily
but i think we also find these
traditions within our own
culture i think we find something very
similar
in the socratic tradition we find
something
likewise in the hellenistic philosophies
which also
recognize that human flourishing which
is a term i very much like
is essentially an ethical practice it's
a way of being in which we take our own
subjective
assumptions to task we don't just assume
that everything we think and feel is the
way
things actually are but we begin to look
more critically
we pursue what socrates calls an
examined life
remember an unexamined life is not worth
living he said
so what is this examined life and
perhaps like yourself and others i found
in a way
more richness in asian traditions
because they don't just talk about these
things but they have
actual living methodologies and
practices
that if followed can lead us to a
radical change of mind
can begin to unfold different
layers of human experience that are
often blocked
and somehow ignored and cut off from
what we experience from moment to moment
yeah exactly so there's this valid
project then
of exploring i think the internal
and the subjective point of view in
a rigorous way which leads to a project
of something
like living an examined life and from
that perspective one can come to
experiential kinds of wisdom and
i think can get in touch with kinds of
skillfulness
and wisdom which in over-reliance or a
soul
reliance on the conceptualization of the
dualistic mind would fail at and
thinking about like compassion or
discovering
something like buddha nature which i had
been very skeptical of for a long time
but i'm less so now
and heart mind and heart wisdom and the
awakening is i think a valid project
and something that is real and authentic
and i think that that's what einstein
helps to explain
and his credentials i think help to beef
this up a bit for people who
may be skeptical of that project i mean
i
view this partially as for thousands and
thousands of years people have been
struggling just to meet their basic
needs
and as these basic needs even just
material needs keep getting met
we have more and more space for
authentic human awakening
and today in the 21st century we're
better positioned than ever to have the
time and space and the information to
live
deeply and to live in an examined life
and to explore you know what is possible
of the depths
of human compassion and well-being and
connection
and thinking about the best moment of
the best day of your life
and if it's possible to stabilize in
that kind of introspection and
compassion
and way of being i broadly go along
with exactly what you're saying it
almost seems self-evident i think for
those of us who have been involved in
this process for a number of years
but on the other hand it's very easy to
sort of
talk about emptiness and non-duality and
buddha nature and so on
but what really makes the difference
is how we actually internalize
those ideas both conceptually i think it
is important
that we have a clear rational
understanding of what these ideas
convey but also of course through actual
forms of
spiritual practice performing spiritual
exercises
as we find already in the greeks that
will hopefully actually lead to
significant changes in how we experience
life and experience ourselves what we've
said so far is still leaving this
somewhat
at a level of abstraction i've been
involved
in buddhism now full time for the last
45 years
and if i'm entirely honest with myself i
have to acknowledge that
at many levels my consciousness seems to
be much the same
and there are moments in my practice in
which
i've gained what i would consider to be
insights
i like to think that my practice of
dharma
has also made me more sensitized more
empathetic to the needs of others
i like to think that i've committed
myself to
a way of life in which i put aside the
conventional ambitions
of most people of my generation and yet
i can also see that i still suffer from
anxieties and high moods and low moods
and i get irritated
and can behave very selfishly at times
and i see in many ways that what this
practice
leads me to is not a transcendence of
these limiting factors
that einstein refers to but let's say a
greater
clarity and a greater humility in
acknowledging and accepting these
limitations that i think is if anything
where
the practice of awakening goes to not so
much
to gaining a breakthrough into some
transcendental reality
but rather to gain a far more
intimate and real encounter
with the limitations of one's own
experience as a human being
and i think we can sometimes lose touch
with the need for this
moment moment-to-moment humility this
recognition
that we are i think to a considerable
degree
built as biological organisms to
maintain a certain kind of consciousness
that will
i suspect be with us largely until we
die
and i would say the same also about the
buddhist teachers that i've met over the
decades that however insightful their
teachings may be however
fine examples they are of what a human
life can be
the more time i spend with them on a
day-to-day basis and i have done with
tibetan llamas with
zen masters i've got to know them quite
well and i
discover not so much a person who is
almost
as it were out of this world but rather
someone who
carries still with them the same kinds
of human traits and quirkiness
and has good days and has bad days like
the rest of us
so i would be cautious in in a way
setting up another kind of divide
another kind of
duality between the unenlightened and
the enlightened
one of the things i like very much about
zen
is that it's quite conscious of
this problem and one of my favorite
citations is from the platform sutra of
the
sixth patriarch called quenang who says
when an ordinary person becomes awakened
we call them a buddha
when a buddha becomes deluded we call
them
an ordinary person this is a way of
thinking that is perhaps
more close to taoism than it might be to
the indian buddhist traditions which to
me
tend to operate rather more explicitly
within the domain of there being
enlightenment
on the one hand and delusion on the
other awakening on the one hand
non-awakening on the other and then
there's a kind of a step-by-step
path that leads from one unenlightenment
to enlightenment
the zen tradition is suspicious of that
kind of
mental description of that kind of frame
and recognizes that awakening is not
something
remote or transcendent but awakening is
a capacity that
is open to us in each moment and it's
not so much
about gaining insight into some deep
ontology into the nature of how things
really
are but it's understood far more
ethically in other words if i respond to
life
in a more awake way that can
occur for me as well as the buddha or
anyone else
in any given moment and in the next
moment i might
have slipped back into my old neurotic
self and
recognize in fact that i don't respond
appropriately to the situations i face
so i'm a little bit wary of this
language
a lot of the language we find in the
indian buddhist traditions we find also
in
advaita vedanta and so on do tend to set
up a kind of a polarity
that's kind of unavoidable because given
what we're talking about we need to
have some idea of what it is that we are
aspiring to achieve
but the danger is we set up another
jewelers
and that's problematic
i feel that we need a discourse that
is able to affirm awakening and
enlightenment
in the midst of the everyday in the
midst of the messiness of my own mind
now
and the challenge is not so much to
become an enlightened person
but it's to live a more awake and
responsive existence
in each situation that i find myself
dealing with
in my life and at the moment my practice
is talking to you
is having this conversation and what
matters
is not how deeply i may have understood
emptiness but how appropriately
given our conversation i can take this
conversation forward in a way that may
be a
benefit to others i might even learn
something myself
in this conversation maybe you will too
and that's where i would like to locate
the idea of awakening
the idea of enlightenment in how i
respond
to the given situation i find myself at
any moment
yeah so one thing that comes to mind
that i really like and i think
might resonate with you given what you
said was i think ramdas said something
like
i've become a connoisseur of my neuroses
and i think that there's just this
distinction here between the immersion
and neuroses
and then this more awake state with
choice
where you can become a connoisseur of
your neuroses it's not that you've
gotten rid of every bad possible thought
that you can have but that
there's a freedom of non-reactivity in
relation to them and that gives a
freedom of experience and a freedom of
choice
i think you very much well set up a
pragmatic
approach to whatever awakening might be
so given the project of living in a
world with
many other actors with much pain and
with much suffering and with much
ignorance and delusion i'm curious to
know
how you think one might approach
spreading something like
a secular dharma so there's kind of two
approaches here
one where we might make the whys more
powerful
and one where we might be making the
powerful more wise
and so if listeners take anything away
today
in terms of wisdom how would you suggest
that wisdom be shared and embodied and
spread in the world given these two
directions
of either making the wise more powerful
or making them powerful more wise
okay to answer that question i think i
have to maybe flesh out
more clearly what i understand by
awakening
my understanding of awakening is rooted
in
the conclusion to the buddha's first
discourse or what's regarded as the
buddha's
first discussion and there he says very
clearly that
he could not consider himself to be
fully awake
until he had recognized performed
and mastered four tasks the first task
is that of
embracing life fully the second task is
about
letting reactivity be or letting it go i
think letting it be is probably better
the third is about seeing for oneself
the stopping of reactivity or seeing for
oneself
a non-reactive space of mind and then
from
that non-reactive space of mind being
able to respond to life
in such a way that you actually open up
another way of being in the world
and that's called as the fourth task
creating a path or actualizing
a path and that path is understood not
just as a spiritual path
but one that engages how we think and
how we speak and how we work and how we
are engaged with the world so what's
being presented here as awakening
is not reducible to gaining a privileged
insight into say the nature of emptiness
or
into the nature of the divine or into
something transcendent or into the
unconditioned
the buddha doesn't speak that way and
these early buddhist texts on which i
base what i'm saying
have somehow been relegated to the
sidelines
and instead we find a buddhist tradition
today
speaking of awakening or sometimes
they'll use the word enlightenment
as basically a kind of mystical
breakthrough into seeing a transcendent
or
truer reality which is often called an
absolute truth or an ultimate truth
again these are words the buddha never
used
so in my own approach i'm very keen
to try to recover what seems to me
and i admit that this is my own project
i don't think it's a widespread view but
i find this very very helpful
because awakening is now understood not
as a state
that some people have arrived at and
other people haven't
which i think sets up to harsh a split
the duality but rather awakening
begins to be understood as a process it
begins to be understood
as part and parcel of how we lead our
lives from moment to moment
in the world and we can look at this in
four phases
as embracing life of letting our
reactivity be
of seeing the stopping of reactivity and
then responding
in an appropriate way but in practice
this process is going on so rapidly that
it's effectively a single task
it's a single task with what we might
call four facets
and here i would come to what you talk
about
as wisdom wisdom in this sense
is not reducible to some cognitive
understanding it has to do with the way
in which
we engage with life as a whole as an
embodied
enacted person again it's reflect
somewhat the zen
quotation i already mentioned it has to
do with the whole of ourselves
the whole of the way we are in the world
as an embodied creature
and i feel that to make the wise more
powerful
by wise i would mean people who actually
have given the totality of their life
not just in terms of years but i mean in
terms of their
varying skill sets that they have as
human beings
their emotional life their intuitive
life their physical life their cognitive
life
that all of these elements begin to
become more
integrated the person becomes less
divided between the spiritual part of
themselves and the material part of
themselves for example
and the whole of one's being is then
drawn
into the unfolding of this process
within the framework
of this four-fold task and i feel that
if we
are to make the powerful more wise
one would require the powerful to make
not just changes in how they might think
about things or even
gain mystical insights but actually to
have
the courage to embark on another way of
being in the world at all levels and
that is a much greater challenge
i feel and i think we also need the
humility to recognize that although
as you say we do have at our time in the
21st century now
access to traditions of practice
philosophies we have
leisure we have the times and places to
pursue these sorts of practices
we should be wary of the hubris that
thereby we can somehow by
mastering these different approaches we
can thereby
be in a far better position to solve the
problems that the world presents to us
i think that may be true in a very
general sense but i feel that what's
really called for
is a fundamental change in our
perspective with regard to how we
not only think of ourselves but how we
actually behave
in relationship to the life that we
share on this planet with
other beings and this planet that we are
endangering through our activities
the other dimension of course is this is
not going to be something that any
particular individual alone will be able
to accomplish but it requires a societal
shift in perspective it requires
communities it requires institutions
to seek to model themselves
more on this kind of awake way of living
so that we can more effectively
collaborate
i think the buddhist and the advaitists
and the sufis and the taoists and so on
certainly have a great deal to offer to
this
conversation but i feel that if we're
really to make a difference
their insights have to be incorporated
into a much wider and more
comprehensive rethinking of the human
situation and that's not something i can
see taking place in a short term
i feel that the degree of change
required
will probably require generations if i'm
really honest about this
so you see living in a wake life to be
something more like a way of being a way
of engaging with the world
a kind of non-reactivity and a freedom
from reactivity
and habitual condition modes of being
and a freedom to
act in ways which are ethical and
aligned
and which are conducive to living and
examined and
fulfilling life exactly i couldn't have
put it better myself no
that's kind of my perspective yes so i i
wanted to put up a little bit of a
defense here of
insight because you said that it's not
about pursuing some kind of
transcendent experience but having
insight can be such a paradigm shift
that it is seemingly transcendent in
some way
or it can also be ordinary and not
contain something like spiritual
fireworks
but still be such a paradigm shift that
you'll never be the same
ever again and i don't expect you'll
disagree with this but in defensive
insight
into impermanence it's like our brains
are hooked up to the world where there's
just all this form and sense data
and we're engaging with many things as
if they were to bring us
lasting satiation and happiness but they
can never do that
and so insight into impermanence i mean
impermanence conceptually is like so
obvious and trivial to everyone
everything isn't permanent everyone
understands this
but if at a deep intuitive and
experiential and non-conceptual level
one embodies impermanence
one doesn't grasp or interact in the
world in the same way because
you just can't because you see how
things are and then similarly if
one is living their life from within
immersion and
conceptual thought and ego
identification the capacity to drop
back into witnessing the self and for
that to dissolve and drop away and then
for
all to remain is consciousness and its
contents
without a center hey this is post
podcast
lucas again and i just wanted to unpack
a little bit here
what i meant by immersion in conceptual
thought
and ego identification by ego
identification
i mean this kind of immersion
and identification with thought
where one generates and reifies
the sense of self as being in the head
and as
the haver of an experience as someone
having an experience in the head
and thinking the thoughts and executing
all of the
commands of the mind and body
and this stands in distinction with a
capacity
to unhook awareness from that process
and to witness the self as
a object of perception
an object to be witnessed rather than as
the center of identity
and for that to then create
a distance between the
foundation of witnessing and the
process of being identified with the ego
or reifying and constructing an ego
which is the beginning of shifting
towards a perception of consciousness
and its contents
without a center so back to the
conversation
that kind of insight and the
stabilization in that
can be a foundation for loving kindness
and openness and connection
and people experience a great immense
relief like oh my god
i was a poor little self in this world
and i thought i was gonna die and now
i've had this insight into non-self
which can be practiced and stabilized
even in in a normal day-to-day life
through the practices of for example
zogchen
and mahamudra and so this is just my
little defense of
insight as i think also offering a lot
of freedom and capacity for an authentic
shift in consciousness which i think is
part of awakening and it's likely not
just a way of being
in the world do you have any reactions
to that oh i have plenty of reactions to
that yeah
i don't disagree with you clearly of
course
there are moments in people's lives
whether they're practicing buddhism or
whatever it is
sometimes they're not doing any kind of
formal spiritual practice whatsoever but
life itself is the great teacher
and shows them something about
themselves or about life that hits you
very powerfully
and does have a transformative effect
those moments are often the key moments
that define how we then
are in the world perhaps my work
has tended to be recently at least
somewhat of a reaction against the
over-privileging of these special
moments
and an attempt to recover a much more
integrated understanding of being awake
is about being
you know awake moment to moment in our
daily lives
let me give you a couple of examples
with hand on heart
i can say that i have had one experience
which would fit your definition probably
of
what we might call a mystical experience
and this occurred when i was
a young tibetan buddhist monk i was
probably 22 or 23 years old
and i was living in dharamsala where the
dalai lama has his
residence i was studying tibetan
buddhism i was
very deeply involved in it and one day i
was out in the forest
in the hut near where i lived and i went
to get some water
coming back to my hut with a bucket full
of water
i suddenly was stopped in my tracks
by this extraordinary realization
that there was anything at all rather
than just nothing
a sense of total and utter astonishment
that this was happening and it was
a moment that maybe lasted a few minutes
in all of its intensity but what it
revealed to me was not some
ultimate truth not certainly anything
like emptiness or pristine awareness
really
what it revealed to me was the
fundamentally
questionable nature of experience itself
and that experience i will fully accord
with what you have said has changed my
life it continues to do so now
so yes i do feel very strongly that
deep personal experience of this sort of
nature
can have a profoundly transformative
effect
on the way we then inhabit the value
system what we regard as really being
important in life
as for impermanence for me the most
effective meditations on impermanence
were those
on death and again this is from my
tibetan buddhist training impermanence
is of key significance regarding
the fact that i am impermanent that you
are impermanent the people i love
when i was a young monk every day i had
to spend at least
30 minutes meditating on what they call
in tibetan
the impermanence which is death and you
contemplate reflectively the certainty
of death
the uncertainty of its time and the fact
that since death is certain and its time
is uncertain
then how should i live this life and the
paradox i find
with death meditation was not that it
made me feel
gloomy or pessimistic or anything like
that
in fact it had the very opposite effect
it made me feel totally alive
it made me realize that i was a living
being
and this kind of meditation is just one
i did for many many years
that likewise did have a very
transformative effect on my life and it
continues to do so
so yes i agree with you i think that it
is
important that we experience ourselves
our existence our life our consciousness
from a perspective
that suddenly reveals it to be quite
other than what we had thought but
it's more than just as we thought it's
also as we
felt and once these kind of
insights become internalized and they
become
part and parcel of who we are that i
feel is what contributes
very much to enabling this being in the
world
version of awakening in the korean
zen tradition in which i trained they
used to speak about sudden awakening
followed by gradual practice in other
words
they understood that this process that
we're involved in of
what we loosely call the spiritual part
for awakening
is comprised both of moments of deep
insight
that may be very brief in terms of their
duration
but if they're not somehow followed
through
with a gradual moment-to-moment
commitment to
you know living differently then they
can have
relatively little impact and
the danger i feel of making too big a
deal out
of these moments of insight is that they
come to be
regarded as the summon bonum of what
it's all about
whereas i don't think it is i think that
they are moments within a much
richer and more complex process of
living
and i don't think they should be somehow
given
excessive importance in that overall
scheme of things
that makes a lot of sense and so this is
very much rings true from your
conversation you had with sam harris
and the back and forth that you had
there is that you put a very certain
kind of emphasis
on the teachings and many of the things
that i might respond with
over the next even hour you would
probably agree with
you see them as not the end goal you
would de-emphasize
them in relation to this living and
authentic fulfilled awakened
life as a mode of being i think that is
broadly correct and i honor
the insights that come from all
traditions really
i don't think buddhism has a monopoly on
these things at all
you're talking about death i've been
listening to a lot of tiknot han
recently
and i mean even insight will change
one's relationship with death he talks
about a lot
no coming no going no birth no death and
the wave-like nature of things and
insight into that plus i find this
daily mahamudra practice of dropping
back to pristine awareness or
i think in what social they call rigpa
and glimpses
of non-duality and the nature of things
like all this coming together can lead
to like a very beautiful life
where i feel like these peak spiritual
experience moments are
a part of the ordinary part of the
mystery and part of like checking and
seeing
how things are so i guess just the last
thing i'm trying to emphasize here is
that i think the project
does lead to a totally new way of being
new paradigm shifts
much more well-being and capacity for
loving kindness and discovering parts of
you that you never knew
existed or that were possible like if
you've spent your whole life
using conceptual thought to know
everything and you've been within
ego identification and you didn't know
that there was anything else
changing from that and arriving at
something like heart mindfulness
it changes the way you're going to live
the whole rest of your life and with
much greater ease and well-being hey
it's post podcast lucas back again and
just wanted to define a few words here
that were introduced that might be
interesting and helpful to know the
first two are
pristine awareness or rigpa rigpa
is a zog-chen word for this and i think
they both
point to the same thing which is this
original and round of
consciousness which is this pure
witnessing or this
original wakefulness of personal
experience
which all content or form or perceptions
or even the sense of self and the
experience of self
appear in relation to this witnessing or
this
pure knowing which is the ground
of consciousness one can be caught up in
ego identification
or can be obscured and lost and thought
or
anything like this but this pristine
awareness or rig pa
or this witnessing is always there
underneath
whatever form and phenomena are
obscuring it
this is related to glimpses i mentioned
glimpses here
and these are pointing out instructions
for
noticing this aspect of mind
and if that's something that you're
interested in doing i highly recommend
the work and books of lock
kelly he teaches very
skillful pointing out instructions which
i think
help to demonstrate and point towards
pristine awareness or rigpa
which he calls awake awareness and i
also brought up
heart mind here heart mind is
a part which is something that one
arrives at
by unhooking from conceptual thinking
and dropping awareness down into the
center of the chest
where one finds non-conceptual knowing
effortless loving kindness a sense of
okayness
non-judgment and a place of
continuous intuition from which to
operate
but that can use conceptual dualistic
thought to know
but doesn't need to and also understands
when conceptual dualistic thought is
useful and when it is not so all right
back to the episode i don't disagree
with
what you have been saying but i feel
somehow that
we haven't really found the right
language to talk about it in
we're still falling back on ideas that
are effectively jargon terms in many
ways
the people who are involved in buddhism
and eastern spirituality will understand
but if you haven't had exposure to those
traditions a lot of this i think will
sound a little bit obscure maybe very
tantalizing
but so many of these words are never
really
very clearly defined i feel that there's
a risk there that we create a kind of
spiritual bubble in which a certain kind
of privileged group of
initiates as it were are able to discuss
and talk around these things
but it's a language that as it stands at
the present i think
excludes a great many people and
this is what brings me to my other point
and again you were talking in terms of
well-being in terms of living at ease in
terms of being more fulfilled
but what does that mean and words that
haven't yet come up in our conversation
are those of imagination
those of creativity we haven't touched
upon the arts
and i'm always rather surprised to be
honest
in these kind of discussions to hear
very little about the arts
the imagination and creativity and for
myself
my practice is effectively my art
and i do work as an artist that's been
my vocation
since a teenager and uh it got
sidetracked by buddhism for about 20
years but
but to me the creative process you were
saying
we come to experience our ways in ways
we've never suspected before
that we have a much less you know
central
insistence on our ego we're less
preoccupied with concepts and so
this is all very good but to me that's
only
in a way establishing a foundation or a
ground
for us to be able to actively and
creatively
imagine another world another future
another way in which we could be for me
ethics
is not about adhering to certain
precepts it's about
becoming the kind of person one aspires
to be
and that you can extend socially as well
what kind of society do i wish there to
be on this earth
there's this emphasis you come at this
with it's about this mode of being and
acting and living an ethical life
which is like awakened being and then
i'm like well the present moment is so
much better
but there's this sense where we want to
arrive in
the present moment without being
extended into the past or the future
experientially so that right now is the
point
but also you're emphasizing this way of
being where
we're deeply ethically mindful about
the kind of world that we're trying to
bring into being
and so i just want to as we pivot into
your article on extinction unify this
the present moment is the point and
there's a way to arrive in it so
fully and with such insight that you're
tapping into depths of well-being and
compassion that
you always wish you would have known
were there but also
with this examined and ethical nature
where
you are not just sitting in your cave
but you're helping to liberate other
people from suffering
using creativity to imagine a better
world and helping to manifest
moments to come that are beautiful and
magnificent and worthy of life
and that doesn't have to mean that
you're
an anxious little self caught up in your
head worried about the future
well i don't actually believe in the
present moment okay
quite seriously nor does no i've never
been able to find the present moment
i've looked and looked and looked for a
long time it's very slippery it's always
gone
when you check arguably it's only a
conceptual device
to basically describe what is neither
gone nor what is yet to come
but there's no point there's no actual
present moment
there is only flux and process and
change and it's continuous it's ongoing
and i'm a little bit wary of actually
even using the term
present moment i would use it as a
useful
tool in meditation instruction you know
come back to the present moment everyone
knows pretty much what that means
but i wouldn't want to make it into an
axiom
of how i understand this process as
something highly privileged and special
it's to me more important to somehow
engage with the whole flow of my
temporality
with everything that has gone with
everything that is to come and i'd
rather
focus my practice really within that
flow rather than singling out
any particular moment the present or any
other as having a kind of privileged
position
i'm not so sure about that okay and also
creativity i don't think is just some
sort of useful way whereby we might
think of a better world in the future
to me creativity is built into the very
fabric of the practice itself it's the
capacity
in each moment to be open to responding
to this conversation for example in a
way that i'm not
held back by my fears and my attachments
and so on and so forth but
have found in this flow an openness
to thinking differently to imagine
differently to
communicate to embody what i believe in
in ways that i
cannot necessarily foresee that i can
only work towards
and that's really where i feel most
fully alive
i'd much rather use that expression a
sense of total aliveness
that's really what i value and what i
aspire to is you know what are the
moments in which i really feel that i'm
totally alive
that's what is to me of such great value
and i'm also not sure that by doing all
these practices that you
find deep happiness and so forth and so
on i would not say that for myself
i've certainly experienced periods of
great sadness
sometimes of something close to
depression
anxiety these again are part and parcel
of what it is to be human and i like
ram das's expression becoming a
connoisseur of one's
neuroses i think that's also very true
and i'm afraid that the language of
enlightenment and so forth often tends
to give you the impression that if you
get enlightened you won't feel any of
these things anymore
arguably you'll feel them more acutely i
think particularly as we talk about
compassion or loving kindness or
bodhichitta
we are effectively opening ourselves to
a life of even greater suffering when we
truly empathize with the suffering of
maybe those close to us or the suffering
that we are inflicting upon the planet
this is not something that is going to
make us feel happy
or even at ease hey it's post podcast
lucas here and just wanted to
jump in to define a term here that
stephen brings in which is bodhichitta
which is a mind that is striving for
awakening or enlightenment for the
benefit
of all sentient beings that they also
achieve
freedom or awakening and liberation from
suffering
all right back to the conversation i
feel that these
kinds of forms of compassion are
actually inseparable
from experiencing a deep pain something
that's very hard to bear
and i'm afraid that that side of things
can easily be
somehow marginalized in favor of these
moments of deep illumination and insight
and so forth and so on
yeah so i mean like pain and pleasure
are inevitable
but i think it's very true that
suffering is optional and
well okay yeah so well again what you've
just said
is one of the cliches that we get a lot
in a lot of this has come from out of
the mindfulness well
the pain is somehow unavoidable but
suffering is optional
i find that very difficult to understand
the direction that i'm going is
there's this kind of loving kindness
that is always accessible and i think
this fundamental sense of okayness
so that there can be mental anguish and
pain and all these things but they don't
translate into suffering where i would
call suffering
the immersion inside of the thing like
if there's always a witnessing
of the content of consciousness from for
example heart mind there is this
okayness and
maybe at worst bittersweet sadness and
compassion
which transforms these things into
something that is not i would call
suffering
and you also gain a degree of
skillfulness to work with
the mud of pain and suffering to
transform it into
what to han would say like a lotus again
we might be on a semantic thing here
i see if we go back to the early
buddhist texts all most body states they
have this one word
they don't have a separate word for pain
and for suffering this is an
intervention that's come along
more recently in the last 20 or 30 years
i think this distinction
there is dukkha and the first task of
the four tasks is to embrace dukkha
and dukkha includes pain it includes
suffering it includes
anything it has to do with being capable
of embracing the tragic nature of our
existence
it has to do with being able to confront
and be open to death
to sickness to aging to extinction as
we're going to go on to and talk and
i find it difficult personally to
somehow
imagine we can do all of that without
suffering i don't know what you mean by
suffering but it looks to me as though
you've defined it in a fairly narrow way
in order to separate it off from pain in
other words suffering becomes mental
anguish
they often talk of this image of the
second arrow in the first arrow
is the physical pain and then you add on
to that all of the worries about it and
all of the oh it's
poor me and all that kind of stuff
that's psychologically true
i accept that but that's a way too
narrow way of talking about dukkha
dukkha there is a grandeur and a beauty
in dukkha i know that sounds strange but
for me that's really really important
not to feel that these spiritual
practices
somehow can alleviate human suffering
in the way that's often presented and
that we become you know everyone's
smiling and happy which you get that too
i mean
tignet han's approach there's a kind of
saccharine sweetness
in this approach which i find kind of
false and that's one of the reasons also
i
like a lot of the christian tradition
the image of christ on the cross
is not the image of a happy at ease kind
of person
there's a deep tragedy in this dimension
of life that i'm very wary
of somehow discounting in favor of a
kind of
enlightened mind that really is happy
and at ease all the time
of all the different teachers and people
i've met i've never met anyone like that
it's a nice idea but i don't know
whether it's terribly realistic or
whether it actually corresponds to how
buddhists hindus jains and others have
lived over the last centuries
all right your skepticism is really
refreshing and i love it so i
wish we could talk about just this part
forever but let's move on to
extinction you have an article that you
wrote called embracing
extinction you talk a lot about these
three poisons
leading to everything burning everything
being on fire would you like to
unpack a little bit of your framing here
for this article how is it that
everything in the world
is burning and what is it that is
all-consuming and how does this relate
to extinction
okay well i start this article which was
published in the
summer edition of tricycle this year by
quoting the
famous statement of the buddha we find
in what's called the fire
serm where he says the world is burned
the eyes are burning the ears are
burning
etc says the senses are burning the mind
is burning
and then he asks burning with what the
answer is burning with greed burning
with hatred burning with
confusion that's his way of
speaking about what i would call
reactivity in other words when
the organism encounters its environment
it's a bit like a match encountering a
matchbox
and that causes certain reactive
patterns to flare up
and these are almost certainly the
result of our
evolutionary biology that we have
managed to survive
as a race as a species so successfully
because we've been very good
at getting what we want we've been very
good at getting rid of things that have
gotten in our way
and we've been very good at stabilizing
our sense of me
and us at the expense of others by
having a very strong sense of ego
a very strong sense of me these are
understood as
fires in the earliest texts and then
later buddhism begins to
think of them more as toxins as viruses
as poisons that contaminate the whole
system
as it were once they have taken hold
and what i find quite striking is
how this metaphor of fire which was
probably
spoken by the buddha about 500 bc a long
long time ago
and yet when we read that today it's
very difficult not to
hear it as a rather prescient
insight into the literal heating up
of the physical environment the through
living a life of industrial technology
basically
whereby we have managed very
successfully
to develop as we call it industries and
great cities and systems of transport
and electricity and all this kind of
stuff
the consequence has been that we're
actually now
poisoning the very environment that we
depend upon in order to live so for that
reason i feel that there's something
in the buddha's dharma that recognizes
the heating up that occurs when we lead
a life that is driven by our reactive
habits our reactive patterns so the
second of the four tasks
is to let those be is to let them go is
to find a way of leading a life
that is not conditioned by greed and by
hatred
and by egoism and confusion that's the
challenge
of course on an individual level we can
do the best we can
but if it's going to have any
lasting impact on the condition of life
on earth
then this has to be a societal cultural
movement this comes back to something we
already
talked about before if we're going to
make
a difference to our future if we're
going to
stave off what might turn out to be
rapid extinction not only of other
species but possibly even of the human
species
and not within billions of years but
possibly within the next century
then we have as a human community a
global community
to really alter the ways in which we
live
and i do think that spiritual traditions
buddhism and others
offer us a framework in which we can
work
with these destructive emotions and
hopefully
in our own lives maybe in the lives of
those who were able to affect closely
maybe in the lives of people who are
listening to this podcast
can ripple out and maybe in the long
term
diminish the kinds of powers that are at
work
that in many ways seem unstoppable
at one level i can be optimistic i can
see that
you know we do have the understanding of
what's creating the problem
and there is amongst more and more
people i think
a genuine commitment to lead lives that
do not
contribute to such a crisis but i'm also
aware
both in myself and many others i know
that we are complicit
in this process each time we take a
plane each time we put on our heating
system
i had a mango last night and i realized
it came from the ivory coast
i mean that's entirely unnecessary yet i
still go out and get things
again it's a humility to recognize that
i can have all these very
high-minded ecological ideas but
how am i actually changing the way i
live
what am i doing in my life that will
help others to likewise take those steps
i feel that the power of evolution the
power of
greed hatred and delusion which i think
are really just the instinctual forces
that have got human beings to where they
are
are very very forceful they're the
armies of mara
the buddha used to call them and he says
there's nothing in this world as
powerful
as the armies of mara mara being the
demonic
of the devil i wonder for many reasons
whether in fact we are capable as a
human community
of restraining such instincts
and impulses i hope so but
i'm not totally optimistic right so
wisdom as we would have understood it
from the beginning of our conversation
would be
an understanding of these three poisons
of hate greed and delusion
it's coming to understand them and from
this mind of non-reactivity and
awareness one can see their arising and
by witnessing
disidentify with them and then have
choice over
what qualities will be expressed in the
world
one thing that i really liked about your
article was
how you talk about this problem-solving
mode of being
many of our listeners and myself
included and i think this especially
comes from
the computer science mindset is
this very strong reliance
on conceptual dualistic thought as
the only mode of knowing and so like
from the head
one is embedded in this duality with the
world where one is in problem solving
mode
you talk about how the world becomes an
object of problems to be solved by
conceptual thinking and this isn't as
you say
to vilify conceptual thinking or to
vilify and attack something like
technology
but is to become aware of where it is
skillful and where it is unskillful and
so
to use it in ways which will bring about
better worlds
i'm wondering if you can help to
articulate the danger of being
in the problem-solving mode of being
where we lack
a connection with interdependence with
the outside world
where there's perhaps a strong sense of
self from the problem-solving mode of
being
and just to finish this off i'm quoting
you here you say such alienation allows
us to regard the world either as a
resource for the gratification of our
longings
or as a set of problems to be solved for
the alleviation of our discontents
yes okay to me this is a very important
point i i'm inspired in this thinking by
martin heidegger very controversial
thinker but someone i feel who did have
some considerable insight
into this process long before anybody
else and i cite him in the article
his point which i completely agree with
actually is that the problem with
technology is not
the technological machines and computers
and so forth in themselves
but it's the mindset that in a way
justifies and enables those kind of
technological
behaviors to happen and as you said
this is effectively a mindset that is
cut off from the natural world and i
think we can see this beginning in about
the 18th century
with descartes and others whereby we set
up the idea that there is a world out
there
and that there is an internal subject a
consciousness
that is able to distance itself from the
natural world
in order to have the objectivity and the
clarity to be able to then manipulate it
to suit our particular desires and to
ward off
our particular fears now one of the
things that often disturbs me
is that this technological language is
often
used to describe these spiritual
practices
a spiritual technologies this is a term
i hear
quite a lot actually or a rather
unthinking and uncritical use of the
word technique
the technique of mindfulness the
techniques of meditation meditational
techniques
as long as we're not thinking critically
around that term technique
i think very often we are unconsciously
perpetuating
precisely the distinction that we often
in another part of our mind we're trying
to overcome namely
this notion of separation we see this in
meditation
you know if you see your mind as it is
if you recognize what are the
destructive
emotions then you can get to the root of
them get rid of them and then you'll be
happy
that again carries with it a certain
mindset
which is so much part not only of our
western
modern western culture but i feel is
part
of the human condition i think we're
very
deeply primed to think of the world
as something out there and ourselves as
something in here
and we find in eastern religions for
example the idea of rebirth that when we
die
we don't really die we just our mind
will sort of go on somewhere else
which again i think reinforces this
notion that there is a duality there's a
spiritual
inside and there is a material outside
and that's just simply the way things
are and many of the people who
teach zogchen and vipassana and
mahamudra believe very strongly
in there being a mind that is not
part of the physical world that somehow
transcends the physical world that gives
us the opt-out
clause that when we die we don't really
die
something mysterious will carry on
to that extent i feel that i'll stick to
buddhism because it's the one i know
best
i think buddhism can actually again
reinforce this technological mindset
as an inner technology i think that's a
very dangerous idea
and if i go back to that experience i
had in the woods in dharamsala when i
was 22 years old
it was that idea that was
really overthrown it was a recognition
of the mystery that i am part
and parcel of i cannot meaningfully
separate my experience from
what is going on around me again it's
easy to say that
it's another thing altogether to really
feel that in your
bones and i think that requires
a lifelong practice a refinement
of sensitivity but it also requires i
think a much more critical
way of thinking about so many of the
ideas that we take on board without
really
examining to see whether they are in
fact
tacitly reinforcing certain mindsets
that
we would probably not be happy to
endorse
i think all of this goes together if we
are to
engage with this environmental crisis
which
undeniably is the consequence of our
industrial technologies then we have to
also see to what extent
we are complicit not just as consumers
in buying
mangoes from the ivory coast but also as
subjects as subjective conscious beings
who are at one level still buying
into the mind matter split
i get into a lot of trouble with
buddhists because i reject
the idea of reincarnation and the mind
goes on somewhere after death
precisely because i feel it is a dualism
that actually undergirds our sense
is the core difference i would say that
separates us from being participants in
the natural world
i cannot think of birth sickness aging
and death as problems to be overcome
and yet that is quite clearly the goal
of buddhism it's to bring
the end of suffering which doesn't mean
just the ending of mental anguish
which is in a sense just scratching at
the surface but it's
the ending of birth the ending of
sickness the ending of aging and the
ending of death
it's the total transcendence of an
embodied life
and for this reason i feel that it's
very helpful to replace the idea of
solving a problem
with the idea of penetrating a mystery
because birth sickness aging and death
are not
problems they're mysteries and they're
mysteries because i
cannot separate myself from death i
am the one who is going to die i cannot
separate myself from
aging i am the one who is aging and so
on
and to do that is to acknowledge these
things cannot be
solved in the way that problems are
solved
and likewise confusion and greed and
hatred
these are not problems to be solved as
buddhism would often
make us believe they are mysteries too
because i am greedy i am hateful i am
confused
they're part and parcel of the kind of
being that evolution has brought about
that i am one of million examples
and by making that change and i think
that change
for me was put into practice by doing
zen meditation
primarily the meditation of asking the
question what is this
that is a koan or a fadu and it's a
practice that i
trained in for four years in korea and i
did
something like seven three-month
retreats
just asking the question what is this in
other words
getting myself to experience in an
embodied in an emotive way
the fact that i am inseparable
from the mystery that is life and that
for me
is the kind of foundation that can lead
us
into a profoundly different relationship
with the natural world
again i need to emphasize that this is
working against
very profoundly rooted human attachments
and beliefs
i think the four noble truths is again
it's a problem solving
paradigm suffering is the problem
ignorance is its cause get rid of the
cause you get rid of the problem and
that's nirvana
and i think that shows that this
problem-solving mindset is not just
modern technology from the 18th century
in europe as heidegger seems to think
but it goes back to something way deeper
it seems to be
built into the human consciousness
itself maybe
even into the structures of our
neurology i can't really speak
with any authority on this thing but
that's my sense
and i can also hear the transhumanists
and techno-optimists
screaming who want to problem-solve the
bad things that evolution has given us
like
hate anger and greed you just find those
in the genetics and the conditioning of
evolution and
snip them out and replace them with
awakening or enlightenment that sounds
much better so sorry can you more fully
unpack this
mystery mode of being and what it solves
the being embedded as a subjective
creature
who is witnessing things as a mystery
rather than as
viewing them as a problem to be solved
well again my emphasis in what i just
said was effectively to swing the
pendulum back to a perspective that's
usually ignored
in practice we need both obviously
it would be absurd to be just an out and
out technophone
and to reject technology and to reject
problem solving per se
that would be silly technologies have
been enormously beneficial to us
in so many ways look at the current
pandemic it's quite amazing how we've
been able to identify the virus so
quickly
how we've been able to then proceed
towards developing vaccines
this is all because of our extraordinary
medical technologies
and that's great i've no problem with
that at all the real
issue is when we start to think that a
technological way of thinking
is the only way of thinking in the same
way that you said earlier that we tend
to think that
conceptuality and duality and egoism are
the only ways of being
i think we have to add to that a
technological mindset
i think that is just as much part of the
problematic as greed hatred and delusion
i think it is a form of delusion i think
it's a very primary form of delusion
so in practice that's the challenge
is to differentiate between those
areas of our life when it is useful to
stand
apart from let's say a novel corona
virus and look at it under a microscope
very useful very necessary but not to
let
that way of thinking become normative to
the whole way we lead our lives
and to open ourselves to the
possibility of encountering
the world and ourselves our mental
states
other people not as problems but as
mysteries
and to be able to value
that dimension of our experience without
reducing it to
a technological kind of thinking but to
honor it for what it is is something
that cannot be captured
by concepts by language yeah they go
together and i think the distinction
here is subtle and people might be
reacting to this and maybe a little bit
confused about the efficacy of relating
to things
as a mystery as i am a little bit but
let me see if i am capturing this
correctly
i can sense myself suffering right now
taking
the attitude and view that my
neuroses and my sufferings
and my pain are problems to be solved
it creates a duality between me and them
it creates this adversarial relationship
i'm not willing to be with them or to
experience them
it's this sense of striving or craving
for them to go away or to be other than
what they are
and i think that's why i am sensing
myself suffering right now
taking on the problem-solving sense of
you but if i
just identify with that and i begin
witnessing that and i
shift to you know these are mysteries
and there is this sense of beauty
that is compelling to you which i can
sense and this kindness and compassion
and ease towards them
but this doesn't mean that the
problem-solving sense
goes away there's more of a dropping
into heart into being
and to willingness to be with them and
explore them and to be skillful
in their unfolding and change but that
is in its sense still
a kind of problem solving i mean there
are parts of me that are unwanted
but there's a way of coming to issues
which are unwanted
and seeing them as mysteries and being
with them in an experiential way
other than the industrial
20th century ego identification
conceptual
thought problem solving mode of being
which feels quite samsaric
like you're in a hell realm of hungry
ghosts in the mind
everything needs to be different how do
i think all the right thoughts to
change the atoms to make the problems go
away
hey it's post podcast lucas and just
wanted to define the word
samsaric here which i mean
as a conditioned pattern
of thought which is motivated and
structured by
ignorance or confusion as well as
craving
and so i see this kind of
structure also applying to the
problem-solving mode of thought which
has this element of craving
and confusion of separateness
that leads to this sense of suffering or
disease
all right back to the conversation and
so it seems to me subtle like that does
this capture what you're pointing toward
i think it is very sad and again i would
also
concur that yes there are parts of our
inner life our psychology that can be
effectively
dealt with by inner techniques like for
example if we're extremely distracted
all the time
if we train ourselves to be more focused
if we do concentration exercises
do shama to practice over time we can
get better at not being distracted
and that's the application of a
technique so there are
aspects of spiritual practice not a term
i'm terribly fond of but let's stick
with it
i think the cultivation of mindfulness
the cultivation of concentration
cultivation of application for example
all of these things
have a technical aspect to them and you
know if i do therapy
i've got some neurosis like chronic
anxiety
i'm not going to resolve that by saying
how mysterious it
wow this is wonderful being in the
mystery of anxiety
that's not what i meant what i meant is
that that is something that we can
recognize as being a problem a
legitimate
problem it's unwanted yeah it's unwanted
and it's unwanted for good reasons
because it prevents us from living
fully from being fully alive it
constrains us from living
it keeps us locked up in a little bubble
of our own neurotic
thoughts and we can find technologies
psychotherapies that if we apply them
can actually
effectively help get rid of that problem
although
as both freud and jung were quite clear
the problem will not just
evaporate it'll still be there but we'll
be able to live with it better
jung's idea was that we get to the point
where instead of the neurosis having
you you have the neurosis and in some
ways i think a lot of these neuroses are
going to be around whether we like it or
not
but we can in a way have them rather
than them having us and that is a form
of therapy
that is a form of cure but when we come
to these deeper spiritual values
let's say wisdom or compassion or love
i find it very difficult to understand
how these
are qualities that we can arrive at by
simply pursuing a set of technological
procedures i think and i've again
witnessed this in myself in others
colleagues
friends monks and whatnot people who
have dedicated years and years and years
and years and years to cultivating these
inner qualities of mind but in some ways
don't really seem to have become
significantly wiser or more loving
i really question whether wisdom
is something that can be produced
by becoming an expert in certain
meditation techniques
or life i think these are qualities that
are meta-technical they're beyond the
reach of technique
and i think suffering in the deeper
sense of
existential suffering which is
effectively what i think the buddha is
primarily concerned with
is birth sickness aging and death birth
sickness aging and death likewise i do
not think can be resolved
by finding a solution that can render
them no more problematic
and even if you follow the traditional
buddhist way of describing this
that's effectively what happens it's
only when you're dead that you are
freed from birth sickness aging and
death so
birth sickness aging and death are
mysteries but a great
amount of what we suffer from within our
inner lives within our social lives
within our world
our problems if correctly identified as
such
that can be dealt with through applying
techniques the challenge and this is i
think
perhaps where you talk of subtlety is to
be able to differentiate between
what is actually a mystery and cannot be
solved as to
what is a problem and can be solved
western technological society
particularly
really has no room at all for this
mystery
focused way of life we might get it in
church on sundays a little bit of it
but we seem to have almost disconnected
from that whole side of life and i feel
that
one of the reasons we're drawn to some
of these eastern
spiritualities is because they seem to
bring us back
to that quality of awareness but if you
don't like the word mystery and a lot of
people
feel a little bit uncomfortable with it
just think of it as i do a lot of the
time
that we live in an incredibly strange
world that it's extremely weird
that you and i are having this
conversation that i never cease to be
utterly astonished and amazed by the
most banal things
and i think it's to be able to recover
a sense of the extraordinary within
the utterly ordinary that enables us to
begin to have a very different
relationship to the natural world
that we're threatening and i feel that
if we haven't embodied
that sense of strangeness of
not only strangers but the same
recognition that i cannot separate
myself from these things i cannot
distance myself from these things they
are infinitely close
that's another definition of mystery
ground of your being
yeah if you want but remember that this
is a term coined by paul
tilley the christian theologian in the
1960s
and he understood the ground of being to
be a groundless ground
which is beautiful a ground which is
like an abbots literally in german
so if we talk of ground of being be very
careful not to make the ground too
solid it's a ground which is no ground
and that again is very close to buddhist
thinking
it's so yeah it seems subtle in the way
that
you're still solving problems from this
way of being
but from embodying this
experiential relationship and
subjectivity in the world
it changes and modifies in skillful ways
perhaps the three poisons
and it allows you to be more skillful is
what you're saying it's not like
you pretend like problems don't exist
it's not like you stop solving problems
it's the there's a lot of skillfulness
in the way that this modification of
your own subjectivity
leads to your own being in the world so
i'd love to wrap up here with you then
on talking about
effective altruism in this field the
future of life institute is concerned
with all kinds of different existential
risks and we're contextualized in the
effective altruism movement
which is interested in helping all
sentient beings everywhere
basically by doing whatever is most
effective in that pursuit
and which leads to the alleviation of
suffering and the promotion of
well-being
as potentially narrowly construed though
that might not be the only ethical
framework you might decide what would be
effective interventions in the world now
what this has led to
is what we've already talked about here
which is this extremely problem-solving
kind of mind
people are like very in their heads and
interested and reliant on conceptual
thought to basically
solve everything like ethics is a
problem to be solved
if you can just get everyone to do the
right things the animals will be better
off there will be less factory
farms we'll get rid of existential
threats we can
work on global poverty to do things that
are really effective
and this has been very successful to a
certain degree with this approach
tremendous suffering has already been
alleviated and hopefully still will be
but it lacks many of these practices
that you talked about perhaps it suffers
from some of the unskillfulness of the
problem-solving mindset
and there isn't any engagement in
finding
natural loving kindness which already
exists in us or cultivating
loving-kindness in our activities and so
there's not much emotional connection to
the benefactors of the altruism
and there's not sufficient perhaps
emotional satisfaction felt from the
good deeds that are performed
there's also lots of biases that i could
mention that exist
in general in the human species like we
care about people who are closer to us
rather than people who are far away
that's a kind of bias
children are drowning in shallow ponds
all over the world and
no one's really doing anything about it
shallow ponds being places of easy
intervention like you could easily save
that child
and so this conversation we're having
about wisdom i think for me
means that if effective altruism were
potentially able to have its
participants shift into a non-conceptual
experiential embodying of perhaps kinds
of insights or
a way of being that you might support as
living an examined life
and as a method of awakening and perhaps
insight into into emptiness and
impermanence and not self and suffering
i think this could lead to
transformative growth that might
upgrade our ethics and experience of the
world and way of being and could de-bias
some of these biases which lead to
ineffective altruism in the world
i think that seeing through non-self
that really kind of annihilates
caring about people closer to you rather
than far away from you or people who are
far away in time
for those who are interested in
existential threat so
i'm curious if you have any reactions or
perspective here about how
the insights and wisdom of wisdom
traditions and perhaps a secular
buddhism and secular dharma could
contribute to this community
i have to confess that when confronted
with these kinds
of problems the ones you just very
clearly
presented i really see considerable
shortcomings
in both the buddhist community and in
this broader
spiritual community that we might feel
we're part of
because in the end a lot of these
practices
are effectively things we do on our own
and
we may do them within a small sangha a
small community
we may write books we might get more and
more people practicing mindfulness that
is all very well
but i'm not actually convinced that
simply by
changing individual minds and if we
change enough individual minds
we'll suddenly find ourselves in a much
healthier world
i think the problems are systemic they
are built
into the structures of our human
societies
they're not intelligible purely as the
collective
number of individual deluded or
undiluted minds
but i think we're going into the sort of
territory of systems theory
whereby groups and systems do not behave
in such a way that can be predicted by
analyzing
the behavior of the individual members
of that
system i think if i'm getting that
correct and
again i'll just speak about the buddhist
community but it of course probably
refers to others as well
i think the great challenge of the
buddhist community is that it has to
come up with a social theory it has to
come up with
a way of thinking that goes beyond the
person
and that is able to think more
systemically
now there are buddhist thinkers who are
trying to do that people like david
lloyd would be a very good example
but nonetheless i don't feel that we've
really
grappled with this question adequately
and i have to admit to my own confusions
and
limitations in this area too i feel that
my writing which is my main work
is slowly evolving in this direction
and what really pushed me in this
direction
was an essay by catherine ingram who you
may have heard of
called facing extinction and i borrowed
it effectively my
essay called embracing extinction is an
acknowledgement of my debt to her
i had been part of the green movement
for the last 30 odd years or so but it
was only on reading catherine's piece
that i suddenly was struck viscerally
by the fact of our creating
a world that could well lead to the
extinction of all species within the
next century
or so and i think we thereby need to be
able to respond to these dilemmas
at the same pitch and at the same level
in other words the visceral level in
which these questions are beginning to
emerge in ourselves again i go back to
zen
one of the favorite sayings of my
teacher
was great questioning great awakening
little questioning little awakening no
questioning no awakening in other words
our capacity to be awake is correlated
to our capacity to ask
questions in a particular way if we have
intellectual questions or let's say
problem-solving questions
then we can resolve those questions by
coming up with solutions
but they'll be at one level operating at
the same pitch
in other words they are conceptual
problems they're intellectual problems
great awakening arises because we're
able to
ask questions at a deeper level so if
you take
the legend of the buddha the young
prince who goes out of the palace he
encounters a sick person an aging person
and a corpse
and that is what triggers within him
what in zen is called
great questioning or great doubt great
perplexity
and the practice of zen is actually to
stay
with those great questions and to embody
them to get them to actually
penetrate into your flesh and bones
and they're within such a perspective
one then creates the conditions for a
comparable
level of visceral awakening
that now i feel has to be extended on a
communal level
we have as a community whether it's a
small intentional community of buddhists
or a larger human community be able to
actually ask these questions at a
visceral
level and the kind of empathy you speak
of i feel also
has to come from this degree of
questioning
i think there's often too much of an
understandable sense of
urgency in a lot of these questions but
that
urgency often just causes us to
immediately try to go out and figure
what we can do
that's probably a good thing but we
maybe do not
allow enough time to really
allow these questions to land at a deep
visceral
level within ourselves such that answers
can then
begin to emerge from that same depth
and that is the kind of depth i feel
that
if we are to come up with a more
systemic philosophy
a social theory maybe an economic theory
that is grounded in such
depth that will perhaps be able to
guide us more effectively towards being
effectively altruistic
but that's kind of really where i'm at
with this at the moment
and my work as it's evolving in what i'm
writing now for example i'm writing a
book called
the ethics of uncertainty where i'm
trying to flesh this out more fully
but this is where i feel my life is
going but i don't know whether i'll live
long enough
to actually you know do more than climb
a few more steps if i'm lucky
but i'm very moved by my colleagues and
friends who were very much involved in
the
extinction rebellion demonstrations
particularly in london
i have a number of close friends who are
very involved with that and that
likewise
i found a great source of inspiration
and
something towards which i would very
much hope for my writing and my
philosophy to be able to contribute
so that's kind of where i'm going i
think that
humanity does face an existential crisis
of
a major order at the moment and i see
all kinds of forces that are railed that
are sent in and not in our favor
the least of which is the four-year
election cycle i just wonder how
national governments who
are in effect beholden to electorates
whose needs are probably largely about
can i get work can my
kids get a good schooling good
healthcare system that's going to be the
priority
for most people frank it's all very well
talking about saving
the environment but when push comes to
shove
again your bias will be basically my
kids
my immediate community or my nation and
we have to get beyond that we can't
think in national terms
anymore there are transnational
movements and i think
that they certainly need to be developed
and further strengthened
but can such transnational movements
ever
achieve the kinds of power that will
enable changes to occur on a global
level
i can't see that happening in our
current world i'm afraid
i find very distraught by that and when
you see some of these right-wing
populists
they're effectively pushing back in the
other direction and then
unfortunately on the ascendant i do not
feel
at all optimistic given our situation
but as a person who tries to lead a life
governed by care and compassion and
altruism
you know i cannot but seek ways
of embodying those feelings in actions
and as a writer that's what i'm probably
best at doing
and i'm very glad i've had the
opportunity to be able to
speak to you and to the future of life
community
about my ideas but i don't know whether
i really have a great deal to say that
it's really going to change the
paradigm that we are i think all of us
are working towards
another paradigm all together well thank
you steven i've really really enjoyed
this
conversation and to just close things
off here
instead of making powerful people more
wise or wise people more powerful
maybe we'll take the wise people and get
them to
address systemic issues which lead to
and help
manifest things like existential risk
and animal suffering and
global poverty that would be great that
would be wonderful
thank you very much luke it's been a
lovely conversation and i really wish
you all the best and
all of those of you who are listening to
this likewise
yeah thanks so much stephen if if people
want to follow you
or to check out more of your work i've
really enjoyed your books on audible
but if people want to follow you or find
more of your work where the best places
to do that
i have a website which is
www.stevenbatchler.org
or the main institution i'm involved
with is called bode college
bodhi hyphen college college.org
and there you'll find information on the
courses that i lead through them
and next year in 2021 i'm leading a
series of 12
seminars on secular dharma which i'll be
addressing a lot of the questions that
have come up in this podcast
and it will be an online course once a
week for 12 weeks
12 3 hour seminars it'll be publicized
in the next few weeks we're just
finalizing that program
as of now so thank you all right thank
you steven it's been wonderful
if you found this podcast interesting or
useful
consider sharing it on social media
forums
with friends or wherever you think it
might be found valuable
we'll be back again next month with
another episode in the fli podcast
you